[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are wrapping up
the season the 2021s i mean we don't
really call them season but we're
wrapping up your biscuits for 2021 by
encapsulating the top 10 moments of each
of our lives
well in 2021 yeah so the top 10 moments
of the year and
order this in reverse order in reverse
i love this episode
you know it for you don't know how bad
it's going to be man just stop
you're saying you like this category of
episode this episode may be a train
wreck you don't know what's going to
happen well i know what my twin are you
could have in a larger reaction to that
jacket yeah i mean you haven't worn it
very much i don't know anything could
happen i have a good feeling
i because i like to reminisce and i
think it's very healthy to put things in
perspective as i've prepared for this
i actually
experienced the positive benefits of of
kind of zooming out and having a having
a perspective on this year so we'll each
alternate starting with our number 10
and culminating in our number one
moments of the year and
i think this is a very healthy thing
even if there's
painful or negative parts of it these
are not they don't all have to be
positive moments well
mine are
okay uh yeah and we should say that like
you said this is our last episode
we will be back with fresh new 2022
episodes starting on january 10th of
that year
yeah which i guess is also the first
episode of good mythical morning season
20
what is it season 20 what
i don't know the next season of james
we'll be celebrating the 10-year
anniversary of the morning anniversary
10 years of good mythical morning so i
got quite a week planned that that don't
sleep on second week in january we're
coming back strong
i mean one of the things we talked about
as we were getting you know
independently putting these lists
together is
um
i the comment i made to you was
man it's not i i mean honestly it's kind
of difficult to come up with 10
um
podcast worthy moments
now it did feel that way about this year
once i dug into it i realized okay well
actually i ended up having to take some
off the list and i got to 10 that i feel
good about but
a lot of the things that i was thinking
about when i actually went back and
looked at my photos and looked at my
calendar it was like oh that actually
didn't happen in 2021 like oh that was
the end of 2020 yeah this year 20
definitely blurred into this year yeah
and 2021 flew by and
you know we were getting back into a lot
of things and you know traveling more
and kind of getting more normal than we
were in 2020 but
man it's it's a not quite normal enough
yeah it's still not normal
and you know what i'd like to just get
started with my number 10 because i
think it plays right into what you're
saying okay so my number 10
meaningful moment my precious moment
of 2021 precious moments is
no wouldn't that be cool though christie
would just go nuts do they still make
them i don't know she doesn't collect
them anymore and she did she could
probably get sponsored by him
just in life just saying
my number 10 is
getting my first vaccine
in march
and i'm not trying to go political well
no don't even go political right from
the start i don't even want to vaccines
aren't political man exactly and that's
why i'm not going there even though
somehow that's exactly where we still
are
as a country
but you know this was in march
and
it was a milestone
you know lincoln and i drove together we
did this dr we signed up and we did a
drive-through vaccination and there was
so much build up to it
when am i
when can i sign up how's the app going
to work it's like what are the
requirements
we've been through so much of
in 2020 and now we have this
this miraculous
vaccine that happened miraculously quick
um
and it was suspiciously quick it was an
it was just a moment joke it's a joke
come on joe it's a joke stay with me
it's a joke i'm trying to this is about
me okay
i just really had a sense that that
moment
that i was living history
and that's what i was telling lincoln
we're living history now we're getting
history shot into our arms we're getting
injected
with
an era
a time that people will always refer to
hmm
now tell us about all the side effects
you've been suffering from all year uh
yeah i've i have not gotten covet
[Laughter]
i haven't gotten it yeah you know this
is uh this is not on my list but i'll
piggyback off of i mean it wasn't it a
moment for you to get the freaking
vaccine you know it's in it right
because it it it represents so much well
here's that we've been through this is
what i remember thinking so you know
i've gotten a lot of vaccines in my life
because i'm a person who lives in the
21st century right and this is sort of
what we do to address disease and we've
always done it this way
but all of a sudden it became
the mark of the beast this year for
reasons that i don't fully understand
but
i remember because so much had been made
of how
i've never been scared of a vaccine i've
never had any hesitation about a vaccine
it's always been an afterthought it's
like oh you're going to get this vaccine
you got to get this vaccine to go to
this country you got to do whatever it's
just you just go and you get it and
you're a little bit feel a bit weird for
a day and then it's over right
because so much focus had been put on
these vaccines and oh it's a new
technology you know it was rushed and
all the media's in there this bill gates
is trying to control you and all this
stuff none of none of it that i believed
i found myself at dodger stadium when i
got my first dose
of the moderna vaccine is what i did
uh the first dose
that you're in this you don't even get
out of your car you're kind of going
through the drive-through they give you
the dose and then they're like okay wait
here for 15 minutes yeah and it was
basically like wait here 15 minutes to
see if you have some sort of reaction
that requires an emergency i've never
had any
sense of worry
or concern
but in that 15 minutes the first half of
that 15 minutes is when i was like i
started letting all the information and
misinformation that had been going
around kind of infiltrate my thoughts
and i was like is something going to
happen to me is something going to
happen of course nothing happened to me
it ended up going on and then i got my
second dose and i didn't even think
about it at that point and yes i did get
my booster already and the booster was
just like going into the pharmacy and
sitting down he was like which arm i was
like left and it was booming i was out
there was no like sit around and see
what happens it was like we know
nothing's gonna happen to you like very
likely that you might die on the way
home in a car crash but you're probably
gonna be fine
but yeah that first moment
was
very significant because of what had
been made of it in a way that
i've never even thought about a vaccine
before yeah i just thought of it as this
is
i'm we're making history here and this
is something that will always be talked
about and
in making it my number 10 moment it
represents
something larger
for yeah like you were saying for 2021
things started to open up especially
when you got fully vaccinated from a
work perspective i think
at least for the two of us not for our
entire team by any means but for us
our work lives
approached
normal like they're not really normal
it's kind of hard to remember what
normal was pre-pandemic
but we we kind of we got back into work
to a point and engaged to a point where
we're very busy
um and and it continues to ramp up
but there was an incongruity
if that's a word between our our work
lives really ramping up in our personal
lives still kind of being
stifled
by the pandemic and again a lot of that
still continues but this is my this is
my moment to
memorialize all of the steps that we
went through and all of the little
moments of the first time that you go
out to dinner outdoors with your family
and you're taking your mask off at the
table and it's like you start to have
these
it's strange feelings that
whole swaths of humanity never go
through and of course um
you know we're fortunate and there's
it's still very serious even this
morning christy told me that some of her
um parents friends a friend passed away
from kovitt
like she found out about it yesterday so
it's it's you know this is not something
in our rear view mirror sadly
um
yeah let's leave it at that you know but
yeah here we are um at the end of this
year well my number is still part of our
lives my number 10 and we'll continue to
be does tie in a little bit to this
because it's you know and again this is
going to be the case for a number of the
things on my list and so
for many of the points on my list and i
would assume the same is true of yours
there's a podcast episode from this year
that that basically goes into detail
about this thing yeah
maybe maybe there's a little space you
have a different perspective or an
update um or not well this one is
my trip to to san diego with my in my
family trip in the spring to san diego
which is what i when i talked about it
on here biscuits earlier this year i
talked about the moment of
lock and shepherd and i being able to
surf together oh yeah and how that was
just like a super special thing and it
was like shepherd kind of getting the
surfing thing down a little bit more for
the first time but also me and lot being
able to surf together and actually kind
of getting a party wave like surfing
next to each other on the way the first
time we had ever done that that's the
moment man um you can close your eyes
and just see it so that was the that's
sort of the moment from that greater
moment that i really remember but in the
context of the nature of the way our
lives have been that was the first
family trip that we took
i think it was the first real travel
that we had done
since the beginning of the pandemic and
it was also the first
sitting down at a restaurant
uh
in
uh you know in san diego out well
sitting an outdoors but it was the first
time we went back and even did outdoor
seating because i remember that because
when you told me
we had been on a beach vacation too
and we hadn't done that we just ordered
in and i was jealous and i was like you
should have told me you were doing that
it would maybe that would have put me
over the edge but everybody's on their
own little timetable of like what you're
comfortable with and you make your own
decisions yeah i mean you know obviously
as i've established very clearly
multiple times on this podcast that i'm
very i take the pandemic very seriously
and i you know i'm obviously preaching
the vaccine get vaccinated the best way
to get out of this thing
uh
but when it comes to my own personal
level of fear when it about coveted it's
actually very very low like i don't have
like i don't have this like anxiety
jesse has
some anxiety about it i don't
i'm just like man okay uh yeah i've been
vaccinated i've been boosted i could
still get it it probably won't affect me
but there's maybe it will like
i don't obsess about that obsessed about
a lot of things i don't obsess about
that i remember
specifically uh sitting down at a
restaurant and i'm just like man i'm
glad i'm at this restaurant i'm taking
my mask off i'm eating yes there's like
this family over here within 10 feet of
us who's also eating and jesse was like
they're they're pretty close to us and
i'm like i can't liv i just can't do it
i can't live like that with a constant
preoccupation with it because i just i i
take the precautions and then i let the
worry go away because otherwise i just
can't function as a person yeah it is
that thing of like if you've never been
on a flight or if you've never been in a
car before you're very keenly aware of
or if like and i'm thinking about this
for lincoln if you're like getting your
driver's license you're keenly aware of
how close you are to death with someone
coming across that center line and then
at a certain point
you put every every every wise practice
into place and you just get on with
driving and if you kept being reoriented
with the severity of the risk every time
a car passes you as if it was the first
time it was happening you would be
debilitated right you don't snap your
seatbelt thinking about why you just do
it because you've made a decision
and it's better to just
always do it and just don't think about
it
and i think this year has been
just the slow
methodical baby steps towards
gaining a comfort level
with
kovid strains being
a part of the news
and a part of reality
and saying okay
i am doing everything that i can
and i am getting on with my life
you know we've we we still have weekly
tests here we still have limited crew
coming into work it's still very
frustrating
for a lot of our crew and it's like
um and i feel for them because they're
in positions that are different from
ours where you just can't be quite as
engaged
and so we're all on these different
timetables and it's not you know it's
not the same across the board but i do
think that these these moments
they're all
covet impacts every area of our lives
and at a certain point you just
you just but you just get on with it
well you do if you're lucky you get on
with if you're lucky i mean if you're a
lot of people who can't who can't uh
maybe it's just you know specific like
autoimmune thing or maybe it's just the
anxiety i mean listen we're still it's a
different timetable yeah we're still in
the midst of a mental health crisis that
we have only scratched the surface
surface of we you know we yeah we really
do not understand
the level
that society has been impacted by this
and not just the
you know the disease itself is one thing
but the anxiety that has been induced by
the way that this has all been
communicated i have a lot of opinions
about that but you know i think that
we'll we're gonna we're gonna look back
and
think about all the ways that this whole
thing was fumbled
you know by our country and by the world
but let me go to my number nine
um to switch gears
i chose as a moment
the hazel horror tick-tock
shoot i debated between the release of
it and the filming of it but i i wanted
to hone in on home and on
you got me in my head about that in that
context just so you know
either one is correct well then exactly
in the way that you used it home is the
original correct version i wanted to
hone in on the filming of it which was
back in august because first and
foremost we did this for
us and it was this just the experience
of removing some creative shackles
again for reasons that we've already
talked about limitations that we have
been under
and then
hatching an idea
that we could take
from start to finish
and get out there into the world and we
had there were no gatekeepers we didn't
have to convince anybody we just had to
align our team
and
it so it was first about us saying okay
we're gonna we're gonna write something
we're gonna do something scripted we're
gonna do something experimental we're
gonna we're gonna utilize
tick tock and we're gonna twist it and
you got really excited about the horror
aspect of it and
the challenge of working with tick-tock
and then involving our team and just the
creative spark
that comes from trying something that
you don't know
what it's going to be like it was very
exciting and for me personally
it jolted me out of a
a creative slump
i mean because it's one thing to not
be creating things outside of the the
the
the playgrounds that we work in within
the shows and the properties that
are ongoing
and that we found ways to mitigate
within the pandemic but it's another
thing to say i'm going to do something
different and i i think i gotten to a
point where there was like a creative
depression
and that was a very instrumental period
i remember when we first talked about
doing it it was i had to make an active
decision to say
i'm going to engage in this
and so remembering that is very
encouraging to me because it was an
instrument of
kind of
reopening that that part of my
creativity
and of course then the the payoff of it
i don't know i don't know where you put
it on your list or if it if you want to
talk about it as a separate moment
because i'm just talking about when we
went out we went out and we were we were
we were working with a team
we were filming on location in the woods
at night and then in our the creative
house like so two nights in a row
pulling all-nighters
switching our
entire schedules upside down and taking
the input of other team members it was
just a lot of fun
to do well it was my number five
um
yeah i and i didn't i didn't isolate it
to one moment you know
if you remember the mythical society and
you and you and you
you know you're present or you go and
look at the answers to the amas you may
see that i i said some things about
people somebody asked about the hazel
project and
uh very recently yeah kind of what our
thoughts were about it
and first of all let me just say that
this time of year is
just
bonkers for us right every single year
everything is it's very difficult to
communicate exactly why it gets so
stacked up at the end of the year but
we've got
you know projects that we can't talk
about and we've got just the aspect of
running a business and wrapping up
seasons and all this stuff and it just
getting ready to go home you know leave
and there's some pre-taping for things
that are in the new year so then there's
this like you're living in the future
you're living in the present and you're
looking back at the year with like
employee reviews
uh this podcast so it's it's a lot at
once like being pulled in different
directions even in in space and time
yeah so it's difficult so i and we had
an ama scheduled and of course it was
like
like everything most of the time
year-round it's just like the ama has
scheduled there's something before and
there's something after it it's not like
it's just like what do you have today i
have an ama no i have an ama and seven
other things right
so i was kind of in i wasn't in a great
mood it's probably reflected in some of
my answers during that time
uh but somebody asked about hazel and i
kind of just i the way that i talked
about it was
you know
in retrospect it was a disappointment
for me because i mean i agree with
everything that you said in terms of
the you know the fulfilling nature of
being able to create something from
start to finish and put it out there
but of course we know that it didn't end
up performing
you know compared to like some of the
really
dumb tick tocks that we do that take
about four minutes to come up with in
one minute to shoot to get
10 times as many views that was a little
disappointing we kind of know why that
happened but then we put it on youtube
it was also kind of like uh nobody
really cared now
what i did say is that i was very
encouraged by all the feedback that we
got from mythical beasts
and and this may have come acro i didn't
mean for this to come across like an
insult if it did but i said that in some
ways it's like i really appreciate all
the feedback from the mythical beasts
but
at the same time it's like when your
grandparents come to your
school play
and they and they talk about how great
of an actor you are
and you're kind of like
are you telling me that i'm a great
actor because i am or because you're my
grandparents in other words we have and
if only your grandparents are the ones
telling you that it really makes you
question it and so i think this is what
i'm saying we have a lot of grandparents
i see the mythical people as our
grandparents no i i you guys
and thankfully i mean this is a
privilege
you have expressed a lot of love for us
and for what we do and so we know if we
put something out there that we put our
heart and soul to and that we're proud
of chances are you're gonna you're gonna
like it and you're gonna appreciate it
but we're always like
is it gonna break outside of the bubble
and the fact that it just kind of
definitively did not do anything beyond
the fan base
was discouraging for me especially and
this is this is a personality disorder
that i have probably not a real disorder
but
um
doing something and then it doesn't get
the reaction
and the feedback that you're looking for
and therefore you
its value goes down that's something
that i'm working on
being able to find the value in the
process
and the execution and the putting it out
there and having it be appreciated by
just a person or just be appreciated by
us and that being the end of it and then
if it's appreciated by more people
enjoyed by a large group of people then
that's just gravy but that's not why
we're doing it i'm working on that uh
but but it was part of the reason why we
did it it wasn't just for the reason why
i put it on my list the reasons i gave
it was also to give an experience to
dedicated mythical beasts who were going
to be there live
and you know we had the we had a get
together in my house a live viewing
party of the posting and reactions and
it was absolutely thrilling that was
probably the best moment actually that
was the best moment because
it was special
for
those mythical beasts who were there for
it and experienced it so to experience
the surprise yeah and to see them
getting on feedback in the moment and
realization of what it was shepherd with
a blanket over his head and just
his eyes peeking out over the top of it
as he watched i was like oh he's he's
he's very very scared so we engineered
it for us we engineered it for dedicated
mythical beasts and we also
designed it with the hopes that it would
be talked about outside of our circles
and when it wasn't
it yeah i think that is a legitimate
disappointment and it's not related to
any sort of disorder because it's what
we set out to do and it didn't happen so
the fact that you put it at number five
even after all that surprises me well i
think it's just in retrospect when i
think about what what it what it
represents
it's i think me putting it at numbers
what does it represent
it just no no i'm saying i'm trying to
have a healthy perspective on it okay so
actually putting it at number five i'm
putting it in number five as in in hopes
that i'm becoming a healthier person
that doesn't need things to be a success
you know a an external success
appreciated by people externally in
order for me to give it a
high value
okay
uh okay we got a lot more to go through
we do want to let you know real quick
that these mugs they're going away you
know we don't keep mugs around for very
long this is probably the coolest mug
that we've ever sold it's color changing
it's still activated
um but yeah this is
the
if you want it you better get it now
through the end of the year right the
design is only revealed when there's
hotness in it
and then a different design remains
when it cools off this one
uh yeah so that's going away we got all
new mug coming down the line
uh but you didn't hear that here yeah
well but you know that's how that's
happening yes we'll always have a mug
won't we um okay my number nine yeah
which i guess is gonna be higher than
nine on your list good mythical evening
okay
it is on my list it is number
[Music]
six on my left okay okay uh what a night
man i mean you know people wanted us to
talk about good mythical evening
uh and we haven't
so this is this is us talking about it
good mythical evening to me
uh
there was a lot of um
i wouldn't say i was nervous
about i mean anytime you're doing
something that is like oh this is live
this is i mean i haven't been nervous
about an episode of good mythical
morning in
years it's like that i mean okay if we
have a guest that i i'm like kind of
nervous to be around or something like
that maybe
which that hasn't happened recently and
there's a few episodes that demand more
of us from a performance standpoint but
but but something that's live
that people have paid for uh that we've
never done before yeah and so and not to
mention that it's
doing things we've never done before
being like being r-rated
on purpose and and i think we might have
different we might have a different
i'll tell you why it's on on my list i
mean
um
to me
i mean yes it was fun to do in the
moment and i think that
uh
especially once
towards the end when we
were you know when britney
became a part of the show you know who
brittany is if you watch good mythical
evening
uh
i mean there's there's very few moments
this this year from a comedic standpoint
that are gonna be any funnier
than when we were trying to manhandle
brittany and get her eyes back in and
all that stuff that happened i mean it's
just like this is stuff that you cannot
plan
that
we can't be that we can we can write all
we want and never be that funny with our
with our writing it's gonna that's the
kind of thing that's gonna happen in the
moment
so i like that aspect of it but for me
you know there's been kind of a very
slow but gradual process over the past
few years
with some notable moments
of us
shedding
another layer of
this persona that p that people kind of
underst understand us as you know
obviously the first big thing we pulled
back was talking about our spiritual
deconstruction and saying hey you
thought we were these guys we were those
guys a long time ago and actually we're
not you know we're not these
these conservative christian guys that
we were when we started this job yeah we
haven't been for a long time but then
being able to do sex timber which is you
know i'll talk about an aspect of that
later but like being able to
kind of talk openly about that stuff and
then it was like good mythical evening
came right on the heels of that
and it was just like hey you know we do
curse
and we do like we do drink
these things happen on a very regular
basis in our lives but we don't ever
share them with you so to me it wasn't
just like having fun
and not being ourselves it was just like
and of course yes we were like we don't
all like i can attest to the fact that
you know when i can link
to my experience he doesn't always you
know it's not like every time link gets
drunk he is the the anybody i'm not
gonna say he was drunk i'm just saying
that like it isn't like link is is like
that every single time he has a drink
but
the fact that we were able to just be be
ourselves is it
that's the thing the thing that i value
the fact that people appreciated it but
the fact that it's another layer of just
like hey
this is an authentic
revealing of who we are yeah it i mean
again i put it at number
six on my list
and
i think a lot of what you said is is
that play that
i think for me
yeah
it put it on the list and maybe put it
higher for that reason first of all
yes it was a gimmick
you know it was a marketing gimmick in a
lot of ways when we when we first hashed
it it was just like you know we had
gotten to a point that we were
we wanted to show more of our
full selves as
responsible adults who can you know
who's responsible
just to well just being adults you know
so yeah it was a gimmick but it was also
like you said it was it's an evolution
of our brand to say
hey we're not don't don't unnecessarily
put us in this box that we're not in
that's you know it's
to never hear us curse a box that we put
ourselves in by the way well yeah that
we built yeah
don't let it we don't want to stay in
the box we built we want to get out of
it
and so it's like okay it would be fun
if you really think about it you know
these guys these guys curse they could
we curse on this podcast
but let's take that to 11
in a prof you know for a gimmick yeah to
just have fun with it
but it then it ex it expands people's
um
it changes how they look at us it
it expands us beyond the box that we've
built you're right
and i would say
the other part of it was
yes i was drunk
but i also leaned into it you know
it wasn't planned
so the story is
um of course we had two full rehearsals
like hours
and hours long were full rehearsals with
the entire crew where we stepped through
everything yeah and then we did it again
once we said okay we're gonna tweak some
stuff we're gonna fix some stuff from a
technical standpoint we're gonna tighten
it and then we did another like dress
rehearsal
and
um
then
before we actually did it of course we
didn't there was no drinking involved it
was like there were segments we were
going to be drinking
right and and cutting the food and you
know it was going to be we knew it was
going to be crazy
but then before we did it
that there was actual drinking involved
and
the just
our discussion ended with oh you know
we'll we'll have some drinks
and
then the thing that i didn't you know
you said you've never been nervous for
something or like keyed up for it the
thing that i didn't realize was that i i
was a lot more keyed up than i realized
there was once i had some drinks
then
wha i went out there and the whole crew
was like
ready and it was like the adrenaline
just started pumping
and that's when i gave a speech to the
whole crew and boy i just i just really
started feeling buzzed like
it just like i was in the present for
you you were not present i heard i heard
i just people i walked into people
seemed confused
everyone had like a confused look on
their face oh link must have given a
speech
right you know the look when link has
given a speech
and then there was a countdown
like to to going live
and then like the heart rate with every
every step of the countdown just like
this is not my experience i was just
like
i was i was going through the roof i was
like excited
and so yeah when the thing started i was
uh
i was inebriated yeah we could tell and
and it well and it was in you know
it was dawning on me
i was like oh no
like
i knew that we were going to drink
throughout and
you know and i was like okay or there
was some segments we were going to drink
and yeah but like i definitely wasn't
feeling
buzzed
really at all
but then i could tell you're a big man
but i was like oh no link is
and so then it was and it was funny
because like hearing stevie tell it it
was like stevie was like oh no
because she cuz she's because she's like
expecting us to like hit different marks
and stuff so there was this adjustment
period for me which i think i would be
much better at this if we were to do it
again i'm not saying we are but if we
were to do it again
um of like knowing that like
i felt this responsibility to be like
okay link is not going to be a reliable
source of
structure structure
and so that left it to me is what i was
thinking until i realized i was like
okay no i don't i guess i don't have to
i guess i don't have to do that role
stevie's kind of we're going to be
responsible for that and think about
that and tell us what to do next i would
say
you know i'm not ashamed of anything
that happened i'm not ashamed of
anything i did and i don't regret
anything except for one thing
and that was that the way that it
happened
it was a it it it put you on the ropes
because it blindsided you uh i know that
the crew was surprised
but
they weren't you know
we're in this together and it was a you
know this was a this was a performance
that we had prepared for and that we
there was a give and take and i put you
in a position where
you had to respond and you but
i know you know that i didn't do that
intentionally because we had a
conversation about it i think
at the mid point where there was the one
break
the point where stevie came back and she
was like
you got can you just reel it in a little
bit we got to make sure we can get
through this whole thing and i'm like
hey
i got this i'm okay
i'm i'm not i'm not gonna go
off an actual deep end here but my main
concern was it that i was putting you in
a position where
you know again you had to respond and it
was something that you were i didn't
want to blindside you and i didn't do
that on purpose
and so that's what i was saying in the
middle of the thing
um
and i appreciated your response
i think you you understood that i wasn't
trying to i wasn't i didn't know it was
gonna come across that way but as it was
happening to go back to the beginning
it was like all right
i had a decision to make
it wasn't that i was so inebriated that
i was i didn't have any faculties the
fact of the matter was
i was very buzzed
and i was
i made a decision
to
to lean into it
to say you know what we've rehearsed
this twice
the
entire crew
has they've got this
so it became an exercise in complete
trust
in our crew
and and you
that you know i had your support and it
was a
i'll put it this way i actually felt
like it was a safe space
for me to just cut loose and to lean
into how i felt so
that happened very early and so it
wasn't just
and so there were elements of a
performance
associated with it
you know it was it was harnessing
the experience i was having
for the for
for performance i would say it was
it was an exuberant expression of
letting loose
but it was an expression of that that i
felt
i felt comfortable and safe doing that
not only with the crew but also with
the audience that was there the people
who signed up for this thing and i knew
that you know
and in the end the reason why i'm not
embarrassed or
have felt the need to apologize for
anything is because
that's all it was nobody was hurt
besides brittany
i don't think anybody was offended or or
or
crossed you know yeah which we didn't
really under we didn't know
we we did but there was because it was
all live i've never had a chance to
communicate that to anybody i just went
with it well i think i mean i think the
evidence is that everybody appreciated
that i i and at the end of the day
um and it was unplanned and i found that
very exciting yeah and i like i said i
mean
i think
i mean i think the only open question is
will we do it again
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be
very difficult to capture the same thing
that happened my knee jerk reaction was
i don't wanna do it again because i
don't you know it's like this
expectation that like well how crazy is
link gonna be next time we do this but
with some having had some space from it
i think there's opera there's
opportunities to dabble in
how can we how could we revisit this
idea again so i think i think the doors
yeah i definitely think it's on the
table and i think that maybe the novelty
of it having happened and us broken the
seal is gone but
you know it remains the fact remains
that we cannot do and say those things
on youtube because the platform doesn't
allow it you know you can't you don't
get this we're going to a different
category so it is something that we
reserve the right to do
again potentially but i yeah it was an
exuberant performance of legitimately
letting loose for me
and i think that that's ultimately why i
put it at number five because or six
yeah i put in number six was because
it was and i saw people tweeting this
that night at least one person that was
like you know i appreciate the fact that
link felt comfortable enough with us
that he could be
he could he could just let him just just
go with it i can't remember how they put
it but i agree with that i think that
was my experience well and i think that
you know and that's where moving forward
i think i would say maybe it was
obnoxious at times and i will own that
well i think for me it was i'd be like
okay well just so you know if we're
gonna do it again
i'm not the master of ceremonies you
know what i'm saying like it's not it's
not on me it's not on me to contr to
control
what's gonna happen next to move things
through logistically it would be like i
want to have the freedom to do that i
didn't feel the freedom to do that
because i felt like somebody had to keep
things tied down but if we were like
stevie it's up to you
and it's awesome it's all on you because
i'm not gonna be i don't like being the
straight man i hate being the straight
man sure you know so it's just like
i think that
if we were if we were i don't but that
could be so structureless that it's just
people can't even follow it i don't know
you know we'll we'll figure it out we
don't have to talk about it anymore now
we need to move on because we got a lot
more to go
uh your number nine uh was hazel shoot
so my number eight is
going back to north carolina visiting
family for three weeks
we devote an entire episode to talking
about it it was
it was the longest i and
my immediate family had been apart from
our extended family since we moved out
to california so that was a big deal you
know and there's a number of moments
that will stick with us
meeting sylvie our
new niece for the first time and
handling all the
the
the affairs of
the
the house and the estate of my after my
nanny's passing
which i believe was a moment from 2020
not being able to go home for her
passing and being there in her absence
was
a difficult
experience
but one that i was i was grateful to
have and to serve my family in that way
so
you know i i had already unpacked all of
that i think
looking forward to going home and seeing
the family again for the holidays much
shorter time now three weeks is a long
time we're doing much less than that but
it's um
it's nice to be able to get back into a
rhythm of seeing everybody
uh moving forward that was you know the
in the north north carolina trip back
home
was number six for me okay uh
i got to see like you said i got to see
family for the first time since the
pandemic
and i got to spend time with my family
the mclaughlins
in the mountains and you know i've
already told about all the stuff that we
did
the highlight from that was probably
like my my dad my brother not getting to
play golf together again
uh and then
the then spending time with jesse's
family at the beach
and the incident of
escaping
the fire the house fire again those are
episodes that we talked we told those
stories in detail if you have not
listened to those
uh i don't remember the title of the
episode but it was you know in the
summer after we got back from our trips
yeah so that whole the that was also the
first that was the first flight
the first pandemic flight
yeah uh so the whole idea of like okay
i'm getting on a plane
gotta keep that mask on got my mask on
on the plane you're not giving us
anything to eat yeah and i'm like okay
you know again i don't once i take the
precautions i just kind of don't like
okay there's a guy behind me who won't
stop coughing
am i gonna sit here and obsess about
this and be anxious about it the whole
time or am i gonna just
be like okay i
what can i do at this point let's just
not worry about it if you get it you get
it um but yeah that was my number six
but since we've told those stories
extensively we don't have to spend any
time there
my number eight
which i also did a whole episode about
was my florida keys trip glitter boobs i
remember that was more recent the uh
having just talked about it is there
anything new
like are you like oh now i'm
i'm going back twice a year i got to get
back to those keys but i miss those
little keys i will say there are just
times when i'm doing
anything at all when just a set of
glitter boobs just pops into my my brain
i mean i could be just doing anything i
mean like once you've seen a set of
glitter boobs that's not true though is
it uh
yeah i mean
they're they're okay there's kind of
nothing like them
and
[Laughter]
no i no i do i do i am i'm thinking i
will go back not for glitter boobs but
just uh oh and by the way thanks to to
all of you who
a lot of people sent messages with
hashtag your biscuits about their
experience
i saw that yeah in the keys once i kind
of told the story
of everything that i saw i think the
best moment from that whole trip though
was the
the uh pirate ship
giant vehicle where the po the the mass
on the pirate ship were like stripper
poles and people dancing down the street
that was probably the old white people
singing [ __ ]
yes or at least playing [ __ ] okay yeah uh
that was the highlight of that trip and
fairly recent that's my number eight
my number seven is um
it it was a pandemic milestone
that kind of brought closure to an era
of the pandemic
in 2020
uh
britain and i started connecting through
instagram and doing listening parties
where we would you know we'd we would
make spotify playlists
under a certain assignment and we'd
collaborate on we present
we we build it together and then we
would experience it live on instagram
along with anybody who wanted to watch
us live
lily showed up for a couple of those and
contributed to some playlists and
there's a lot of memories
and it was a was a
from the early on in the pandemic it was
a it was it was a lifeline it was
something that i talked about over 2020
and towards the end
um
and then in june
of this year
we had one final listening party
i say final because we i mean it's not
like we said this is the last one we'll
ever do but it's the last one that we've
done and we don't have any plans to do
it anymore um but it was in june
the 22nd listening party and britain was
there in person in my house
so it was very much uh
it was very symbolic you know that
hey we've done this thing where we
couldn't be together
in the same space and now things are
loosening up to the point
that
we can be together with a certainty that
we're gonna be safe
and so it was it was very celebratory it
had some
pretty good mythical evening vibes to it
for because i was so
charged up just so exuberant about the
fact that like we were together and it
just
there was a lot of symbolism in it for
me at the time that made it very
celebratory that people were like is
link on something
and it was and uh
but it was it was just
it what i was on was just
experiencing connection
that i we had been waiting for for a
long time and i know that a lot of you
know with our families and with friends
over time over this past year we've had
some get-togethers where
you have that first hug
after
a year and a half of not seeing or being
able to touch this person that you love
and
that's what that listening party
symbolized for me and was was very
special for us
because
it
it was the conclusion of something that
was a lifeline and it was it was a the
best way to conclude it is being in
person wrapping your arms around each
other and i know so many of us have have
been able to experience that so
that's why i put that at at number seven
which is the number
of completion so you're done
no i have i have six other ones but um
isn't that what number seven is oh yeah
it's the complete number for sure number
seven for me
uh
is
sex timber
but specifically having jesse and
christy on the podcast
um
again i for the reasons i already said i
think that
i always enjoy i j i like
i don't know something about
i don't know what it is but i i like
being able to talk
openly about things that i feel like
we've held back right and there's only
so much of that you can do
but
i the whole process of being able to
talk openly about these different stages
and sort of the you know the way that we
thought about sex
was a really liberating and and
empowering just for me personally
um
but my favorite moment was getting
the the ladies on the podcast and having
them be able to speak from their
perspective
which i was which i know was a big
moment for them to be to be a part of
that and to see the way that everyone
responded to that of course there's like
so many people calling for well
we gotta have we gotta have the wives
podcast we'll get let give them a show
you know
listen if
if they wanted a show they they they
would have a show it's not if
if it was up to us they'd have one we're
not allowed to us it's up to them
um
but i think that
that
represents
a pretty significant moment
and i'm not speaking
for christy i'll speak for jesse
i think that you know they've been
through their own journey
through this whole spiritual
deconstruction and the worldview
changing over time
on their own pace in their own way it's
their story is their story not ours
um jessie
i know
being able to kind of speak from her
experience you know what it's like to be
a woman in that particular system in a
way that we cannot speak to or really
even understand it's something she talks
about on a regular basis with people
you know that she interacts with it's
something that she maybe talks about on
twitter or whatever but she's never kind
of come into our world and given
you know had an opportunity to speak to
that and so and i was able to see how
much it connected with other women out
there
who have similar
uh
stories or at least can relate to their
story in a way that they can't really is
directly to us yeah
it was a cool moment um
really i
i guess i didn't
i didn't put it on my list specifically
um
so i'll i'll
i'll just steal it from your list and
because i 100 agree that it was it was
quite a milestone not to just have them
on the show but to but to let them
let them share their perspectives
and that whole series
i think was um
was very rewarding
and and
so that was your number six seven that
was your number seven my number six as i
already said was good mythical evening
which again i i think the common
denominator between the two is
experiencing freedom actively
experiencing being free at a level
uh
heretofore we had not experienced being
able to speak openly about
our views on sex
and our experiences past and present
was
it's it's a great feeling to say
i'm not i'm not going to be held back by
what i'm afraid people might think
about me
um i am going to be myself
and
i'm going to embrace myself regardless
of if other people do and good mythical
evening was an exercise of that for me
um
and
the sex timber was an exercise of that
for me as well
and
it
it feels good
to experience freedom
when
especially when it's a big contrast from
how you've lived
a lot of your life in
and maybe in just in certain pockets
but to have those pockets open up
is is very rewarding yeah
um
i've already talked about my number six
which was the north carolina trip
i haven't talked about my number five
which
this may sound like a smaller
uh
moment
one just just an hour in time
maybe an hour and a half
but it's something that it only happens
once
uh at least
with each child that you have
and so my number five is
lincoln's first driving lesson
back in january uh
i kind of i i kind of took him off guard
because he wasn't he hadn't
he didn't have his permit yet we just
went out to a parking lot that was you
know so it was still
legal we weren't on the street
it was like really we're
we're doing this you're
and
i you know it i all the memories of when
i learned how to drive when my papa
taught me how to drive that pickup truck
that he surprised me with for christmas
that by the way i remembered
when i told that story it was a little
bit different you had called you had
called me christmas morning and let and
we didn't answer the phone and you left
a message on my answering machine
and mom and i could hear you talking
about hey did you get that big red
four-wheel surprise and i'm running over
to four-wheel surprise pick up the pick
up the phone because mom didn't know
that you knew
and you knew because i told you because
i knew that it wasn't really a surprise
and i didn't want to ruin the surprise
and that's how it happened
but i remember when when i'm telling
lincoln how to turn and he's like like
we talked about it's like i don't i
actually don't i never realized what it
feels like to push the brake and turn
the wheel and try to you know everything
is so awkward and it just brought me
back to that moment as a 15 year old
myself in that pickup truck that he gave
me and it was this
it was a rite of passage for him
and for me as a dad
that
he was he was nervous even though he was
there in a parking lot and it was
awkward and he he probably had no clue
that it was like something that was
very emotional and
like a real dad moment for me so much so
that i'm putting it at my number five i
had i i have another uh moment with lock
that i'll talk about but yeah same
parking lot by the way that i think that
was this year
it's crazy because locks it feels like
life's been driving forever
um and by this point but
yes
i i i you don't have to top my moment no
i'm not talking just go to your moment
um
my
my number five was the hazel project
which we've already talked about
my number four i'll go ahead and go to
my number four
uh
okay so we're gonna talk we're gonna
tell you
in general about a project because i
can't talk about this particular week
that was a highlight of
of my 2021 without giving you just the
general and we have alluded to it yeah
so
in 2020 i know what you're going to talk
about in 2020
we came up with an idea for a movie that
we wanted to write now we we have not
uh you know since
since uh gutless wonders back in the day
when we were 14 we've never written a
screenplay like you know we've written
tv pilots
we've written seasons of
of tv things like buddy system and
uh
you know
books
but we've never written a movie right
and so
and it's just we like to have a bunch of
irons in the fire and we have this id we
have this
what i will describe as
ridiculous idea for a movie
that we just were like man let's just
let's just make this movie like let's
we've got this idea for a movie let's
just let's just move to the next phase
of writing it and then when people are
like hey you guys got any movie ideas
we're like yeah we've got here here's
our script this is what we want to make
maybe we can get somebody to help us
make it maybe we can end up just making
it our own i don't know how this is
going to work but like let's at least
get to the script let's not just talk
let's just not get a kick out of this
crazy idea for a movie bring it up
occasionally and then realize it's been
three years and all we've done is bat
around a concept for a movie and as you
might imagine let's let's let's move
this thing forward as you might imagine
given all the content that you see from
us
whether it's this podcast or a good
mythical morning or good mythical more
or everything you see on social media
everything you see on the mythical
society and everything else that's going
on
finding the time to write a movie is not
something that naturally presents itself
in our schedule so i remember this pie
in the sky
uh
we i actually remember
we had conceptualized and even sort of
roughly outlined
the movie at the end of 2020 and i was
thinking i was going to take some time
over christmas break of last year to
like get started on the script
that didn't happen
yeah i mean
i almost put down
and i'm not going to steal your thunder
here with what you're getting at but in
september we did manage to
uh protect an entire day
to complete an outline of the movie
uh so it took until it took until
september
and i would finish the outline and at
the end of that day or at some point
towards the latter part of that day i
remember us having a conversation about
how much fun we were having we it we
don't have that conversation enough
where it's like today was completely
creative
we weren't running a business we weren't
interacting with
our employees as great as they are you
know it was like it was back to a the
basics of just
creating and collaborating it was it was
extremely rewarding especially it was
for me the only day of the whole year
where that was the case coming out of a
creative depression and then saying we
have this day where it's like hey
we can we still can have this experience
and so that day of outlining brought us
to a point where
it that was
i mean just that day
was amazing for me and then it was like
okay and now we can
we need to move to writing yeah and so
and i told jenna
shortly after that i was like listen
i know the stuff that we've got going on
right now and i know the projects that
are beginning to happen and we know how
the end of the year is
we need to
reserve a week
where i can go
to a cabin
yeah it it in your mind it had to be a
cabin and
because that's where writers
write and just do nothing but write and
see if i can write a movie in a week
you're really talking about five days by
the way yeah five days
well and it might have been just four
days because i was gonna get there on
what did i got there on monday
i went there on a monday evening and
then i showed up on the show on friday
uh actually you showed up at friday
friday at like 2 p.m because we had to
do that uh
facebook live thing with
was it with hank green
so i was like okay between monday night
and friday
mid-morning i want to write a whole
movie based on this now again
there's an outline so it's not so it's
not like
pulling things out out of thin air it's
like i know what
needs to happen in this scene but like
the characters have to come to life and
there's got to be dialogue and you're
going to end up writing 100 pages right
and so i was actually like on you know a
couple days before i was like reading
stories about people who would like
busted out scripts really fast like
there's just stories of people being
like i had to get this script strip done
and we and we wrote for four days
straight and we ended up getting it done
but i've never done this before
right yeah so we talked about it a lot
yeah yeah yeah but but i was like i want
to have a first draft done
and uh
i ended up
that
even that first night i wrote about
about 15 pages that first night just to
kind of break the seal and get going on
it right
and then over the course of the next
three days
i woke up about seven o'clock
would start running about 7 30
a.m
and
would not leave the cabin didn't did not
get even get dressed or just brush my
teeth i had food with me
and would write until like basic until i
couldn't see
um because there was no light in this
cabin
and it was
you had an outhouse and long story short
long story short things
time began to blur
there was a couple of times when i would
stop and i would like read through it
and i would be like
and i was and i texted you and i was
like
man i've
i've lost perspective
i don't have any idea if this is any
good
i um
i keep getting to these places where i
think that what we've come up with is
too crazy and i
in in it and then i don't i just don't
know if we should continue and if this
is like gonna be a huge embarrassment if
we ever if anyone ever reads it and what
did i say it was very profound you were
like that's a really good sign
or something like that like i don't
remember what if you're getting to the
place where you think that what maybe
what you're doing is two is too crazy
you're probably in the right place so
yeah i kept going and when you showed up
on uh
friday friday i was like i sat there and
you watched me read it i was like hey i
have we i have a script man i don't know
what i have no idea what you're gonna
think about it
but we have a first draft yeah and again
yeah that's the first draft it didn't
like the first draft is all we have
right now is the first draft
we're working on the second draft
i don't know when it's going to be how
many drafts are going to be
there's a lot of notes it's going to
change again but anyway but now that
we've shared it breaking that seal with
stevie and with mallory
they're not going to let us go another
year without finishing right yeah coming
up with another draft i think in the
next
month or so there's they're going to
hold us to a second draft which is
uh their jobs right and so uh it's very
exciting but again you that made your
list so high because why well
i you know one of the things i've talked
about with my therapist is that i find a
um like
my happy place is in just a pure
creative process right
um
and
i get into a creative flow
when writing
where
the things just start the things just
start coming together
in a way where i know exactly how this
character i want this character to be
represented and what they would say in
the situation and how the this character
would react and it feels like you're
kind of reading a script that someone
else wrote
you know you just get to a place where
it's just like i know exactly how this
character would react
and i just don't get to do i mean that's
that's the thing that i would do
full-time if i could right i would just
create 100 of the time
that's just not how our lives work
that's not the business that we've built
um
so i mean it made my list because
i was in the zone and i was getting to
do the thing that i loved the most
i was reminded that i wish
we could engineer our lives and our
schedules to a place where
it wouldn't have to be crammed into four
days to write a script in four days
right um
well maybe it can one day maybe it will
one day so i'm just i'm not getting
frustrated about it as much as i'm just
being thankful for the fact that it
happened
and it's like once you get once you move
that push that giant boulder up to the
top of the hill
it's like okay now we've got we have the
potential for some some some real
momentum
um
so it just it's just because i enjoy it
so much
my number four
um
and
once i get into my top four
well it was it was tough to order these
in particular order so
i wouldn't read too much into these
um
but i i put it number four lily and i
um making a permanent decision to get
matching tattoos i mean
to it's a moment that's memorialized
forever and it and it's it's extremely
special to both of us you know she's
back home
for a christmas break now and you know i
just i i see her tattoo she sees my
tattoo there's like it's like yeah
there's like a little you know it's it
it
um
that the connection that we have
is there
permanently
unless she like
well i guess she could she could pull a
pete davidson and labor lays those
things off or she could just have an
accident with a laser you have to have a
few accidents with a laser or one
accident with a crazy laser but it was
um
you know for her to turn 18 this year
for her to graduate from college i mean
high school and uh
she she she's had so many milestones and
it was great to be a part of one that
like is is such a
headline reminder such a visual reminder
of our connection was was so special and
the fact that it was her idea yeah um
was really great i'm getting in my top
three are similar they're all about each
one about my family members i will say
my number one's about my wife but number
two and three
random order whether it's lock and
shepard they're a tie they're both tied
for second um so my number three
is uh
getting and actually i'm going to get to
do this tonight when i leave here i'll
get to do this is watching lock play
basketball
so you know
this is he didn't get you know he he
uh he's been playing basketball since
middle school
and
you know he he transferred schools kind
of in the mid like right at the
beginning of the pandemic he literally
transferred to a new school
in january
of 2020 and then the pandemic happened
and so he immediately like okay he's
always okay there's no basketball season
he was actually playing basketball for
the other school anyway so it's like
didn't have a basketball season last
year so it's his senior year in high
school he said he's out of like a small
school where like you can you get a
chance you can play
and it's not you know it's not as
competitive as a school that he was at
so we're kind of looking forward to him
being able to to play but you know
locke does a lot of different things and
his focus on basketball was not nearly
as
uh
singular intense as my focus on
basketball growing up like going into my
senior year is like there's a few things
i cared about but like you could count
them on one hand and one of them was
basketball
and it was like being
the leading scorer on my team and like
us being a good team like it was like a
focus and so as basketball season rolled
around like there was actually a moment
where like right before the season
started he was like i don't even know if
i want to play basketball my senior year
it's just like i have a lot of other
interests and
i was like well you've been going to
these practices you know like these sort
of informal practices and your team is
really small and aren't they kind of it
seems like they've kind of been counting
on you playing
and i just i know his tendency to kind
of move from thing to things so so i was
i encouraged him i said i think it would
actually be a good thing to just like
stay with this commitment
and just see this through and i think
it'll be something you look back on and
be like i'm glad i made this decision to
play or at least something that you put
in your top ten yeah just kidding no but
honestly it wasn't this thing of like a
dad wanting his son to play sports
against his will it was very much like i
know luck so well and i think it would
be a healthy decision and being
committed to something that's got some
structure to it is a good thing
and so
you know they played a couple of games
and i was like i don't know how this is
going to go they got beat horribly the
first game i ever went and like you
could kind of sort of tell like oh yeah
like really hasn't been working on his
game he hasn't been practicing and i'm
going to be very encouraging to him or
whatever
but over the last few games that i've
watched him play
there's like something just
awakened inside him and it was in and
it's like you can see the competitive
nature
of him come out and it's just like the
other night he had 33 points
and then he had 29 points he hit six
threes in one game hit six threes in the
next game i was like oh [ __ ] he's gonna
break my record of seven threes in one
game if i don't watch out
did you tell him he knows about your
seven he's already beat my scoring
record because my career high was only
29 points does he know about seven in
one game um you have to tell him no he
knows i've told him that before though
well then don't tell him too much but
it's it was
in the other night they were they were
playing
and
they were down by
i don't know they were they were down by
going in the fourth quarter there it was
a tight game
and like lock
just took it upon himself
he just kind of took the game over and
he had
i don't know like probably 15 points in
the fourth quarter
and just like making all these shots and
they didn't end up winning it was very
close
it was very close but like i don't know
it's been so funny it would have been a
better story you know it's so fun
because
you know
this is a this is an experience that i
didn't expect to have i mean i did you
know it's like i've seen him do things
like diving and that kind of thing and i
and i was never like i'm not putting any
pr i don't think that he's going to be a
professional athlete i don't think he's
going to be an athlete in college just
like it's more just like this is a fun
thing to do i want to be supportive i
want you to have something that you're
doing that you're succeeding at but it's
just like i saw him playing and i saw
how laser focused he became on
winning
and i was like wow i mean i this is
something that like i i remember what
it's like to be to be out there i didn't
i didn't know he was ever gonna have
this experience of being somebody who's
just out there and it's like i'm gonna
take i'm
give me the ball
like not like
oh the pressure's on i'm gonna pass the
ball to somebody else he's like no the
pressure's on i want the ball and i'm
gonna make the shot just give it to me
and so it's become real it's super fun
to watch him watch and play but there's
a connection there oh yeah you're to
your past and
his presence yeah that's cool and i'm
glad that he gets that experience is his
senior year you know he's like i want to
focus on
lifting weights
and i'm like okay lifting weights is
cool but you don't lifting weights
doesn't generate memories in the same
way that being on a team and and and
playing together against another school
does it's just a it's a different it's a
different experience you know lifting
weights doesn't i'm not hashtag your
biscuits all you uh
jim bros out there and gym gals whatever
you're just saying okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay i know what you get a new pr
everything whatever but i'm just saying
it's a different it's a different thing
than a team sport my number three is uh
christy and i going on our big sur trip
uh
again i'm
my top four is nope i'm not saying that
christie's my number three okay well i'm
just jealous i know what you said well
my wife is number one so you couldn't do
it you don't read into that one
but yeah it was a super special
experience
uh
the rain and the redwoods which i talked
about pretty recently and it was a
rescheduling of our 20th anniversary
after we had already
celebrated our 21st wedding anniversary
and i you know i will i'll always
remember
the two of us
in the cabin
with the rain coming down and it just it
was just about us there was there was
nobody else on the planet
and
there was no place that either one of us
wanted to be
and to be at that point at this point in
our relationship is
you know uh this
a lot of people don't get to experience
that so i do not take it for granted
i'll leave it at that i'm gonna save my
number one
but that's my number one two
not being and with your wife and big sir
but being with my wife and big sir well
then wait until you're number one um so
i'm gonna talk about my number two yeah
that's your next one well but so far
when we've had one coincide we've said
that so well if you give a little space
you could say the same thing and people
might think that uh well i'll say
something different uh my number two
again tied with number three is uh this
is a general memory and then i'm gonna
talk about a specific thing but is my
time that i spent with shepard
uh one wheeling
thanks to your idea of getting the one
wheel
uh this is your number two yeah because
of me is this your number one so does
that mean me your number two
kinda
i made your number two possible well
technically the company one wheel did
but yeah you you buying a onewheel was a
very good decision i'm glad you did it
and i i'll take that um i'm a part of
rats number two and you know the thing
is it's not a gross is the
you know this this specific
challenge with shepherd is the fact that
he you know
especially
over the course of the pandemic
when you couldn't really do anything and
you're doing all your school online he
really made a connection with a couple
of his friends that he knows from real
life and they would play video games
together yeah and they're playing lots
of video games together yeah and i have
just a classic middle-aged dad
perspective on video games which is i
think that they are a total waste of
time now i know that that's not totally
true okay and i know that video games
are not as bad for you say as just
sitting there and watching television
right they're interactive
in a different way whatever
but
i just don't want his childhood to be
defined by playing video games
and that's it
and so
when you got these one wheels because we
will go out and do some things together
but it's like okay if we're going to go
surfing together it's like that oh you
got to go all the way to the beach we're
a long way to the beach where we're at
um
if
we don't we don't really do the mountain
biking thing because my kids never
really learned how to
bike in a way that they can go do do
that in even if i wanted to right
um
hiking is hiking
right it's it's work for a child and so
in their minds the moment we went over
to your house when you said hey we've
got these things and come try them and
it's just like
you know shepard just got on him and
just did it you know he just got on it
and he was gone and i was like okay
and he and he's like that when it comes
to those kinds of things
so i wasn't necessarily surprised but
the thing that was i was sort of and you
know excited about was like
because he said dad you should you you
should get some of those we should have
those
and then we i got him the thing we each
got one and
he wrote it 100 miles in the first week
on his own and i it's less he goes all
over the place on the thing right i
don't even care anymore where he goes as
long as he's got his phone with him just
go man live a life be like a kid from
the 80s and a helmet wear a helmet and
some pads if you can if you remember to
do that wrist guards and a helmet and a
phone and you're good to go but
and then we'll have these days where
we're just like hey it's saturday
afternoon let's go
and just a few weeks ago
uh we went to just a really
special
uh sort of there's a lot of like parks
and sort of open recreation wilderness
areas in la if you know where to look
and it's one that you've been to and you
had told me about and shepherd had been
there because he had done like a camp
there or whatever in like in the same
area but we went and we just had this
day where we were
going on these trails and we just kept
stopping and like literally saying
things that you would say in like an
after-school special which is like i'm
having such a good time don't do drugs
dad yeah and
both of us kind of realizing how good of
a time we were having
and like he he will do it i don't even
if he's in the middle of like one of
these quests on one of his games with
his boys
if i'm like shepherd one wheel he's like
guys gotta go hangs up and we're where
we go right it's like i don't have to
convince him to do it he has such a good
time doing it and he's better at it than
me because he's smaller and so he's
willing to go a little bit faster the
board he can go up things that i can't
go up so that's a cool thing that he's
like kind of leading and going in these
things yeah um and he'll real really
remember if you take him out and he
breaks his wrist well i'm
honestly very surprised that he hasn't
broken something yet it it is
inevitable referring to the fact that's
what happened to lando he's back on it
now he's gonna that that's something
he's gonna hurt somebody he's back
hopefully that won't slow him down so
that's in general but that day just a
couple weeks ago when we kind of had
that incredible experience found like
these new trails and stuff and found
these new parts of la that we didn't
know about
um that's been really special yeah uh
my number two
is
we had an
uh in addition to our family
join us in 2021
uh
he is golden
and peanut butter and in color
but kind of looks like my other dog jade
so yeah jasper came along in february
of this year
and
you know christy had been i was like as
long as the i just want another jade and
i'd love for her to be a peanut butter
jade
and christy really wanted
a dog more than i realized because
jade's my dog
uh very loyal to me
and
i remember when she first showed me the
picture
i was like
this is a peanut butter jade
let's go meet this dog
right now and i i'm pretty sure
i don't know if i told the story here
or on um yeah i'm pretty or on good
mythical more
uh when i introduced jasper to the
mythical beast but um
there
christy has experienced
a connection with this dog
uh jasper was already a year old
and
had
separation anxiety really bad like the
the the woman who was the foster mom
said i can't put him down i have to
carry him all the time because he jumps
and cries just like put him down is
probably not the best choice of words
put him down on the floor i have to
carry him in my arms
and so yeah for the very beginning
christy had to like cradle this poor dog
who was afraid of who knows what
from his past
but um
his his foster mom was a blonde woman
christie's a blonde woman it was the the
handoff was was very
immediate
and the connection that they have
uh is
is
it was
so much i didn't realize the point the
extent to which christie needed that
type of connection at this at this
particular at this particular point in
the pandemic
and what she was going through
and
so she would say i am so
grateful for this dog and
i mean we all love him to death i have
this connection with him as well
he's still
like everybody loves him but he's and
he's he's weird about other family
members it takes him a while it's taking
him a while to warm up
even
having haven't been almost a year with
us
with everybody except for me and christy
but um
he is
he's he's he's brought so much into her
life that it's just been
i mean we can put up with the fact that
like he still has a lot of trouble with
being housebroken
oh man we're having an issue we still
have issues
so it ain't all roses and and slices of
pie i will tell you that by any means i
mean it's it's it's like
caring for a
for a baby that you're trying to figure
out
and he's trying to figure out life with
us well you know i will say when i had
to pick i had to pick uh him and jade up
that's right you know from the dog
border this is the dog border sounds
like some place like the dog nation
i mean like the whatever the kennel or
whatever you call it and um
the pet resort to taking
jasper and jade home
like as soon as i got first of all when
the lady handed jasper was like frozen
like as she handed him out he's just
kind of like frozen just kind of like
his eyes were like really big like
but he didn't growl or anything and i
just kind of took him he knows you and
put him in the car but he was in frozen
mode with the lady and then frozen mode
with me yeah i put him in the car
i start the car up and immediately he
just jumps into my lap
and then i'm like oh is this how it's
going to be i was like buddy you can't
be in my lap because it's against the
law as christy learned you cannot have a
dog in your lap we have a special
carrier now he insisted on jumping into
my lap and i kept having to move him to
the passenger seat and eventually i was
like okay it's not that far 10 minutes
he just sat in my lap with his head on
my on my arm while we rode yeah in the
car and then jade starts barking at me
because she wants me to pet her so i
mean so i'm sitting here driving with
one hand your jasp your peanut butter
jade is in my lap with his head on my
arm and jay and i'm constantly petting
jaden if i stop for a second she barks
and growls and claws at me yeah and so
i'm just like good lord these neil dogs
are so needy yes
yeah it's nice to be needed
i think is what christie and i say
barbara was like no barbara is super
needy at home and she'll bark at you and
stuff like when you drive she wants you
to pet her a little bit and then she'll
go and lay down but no no no not jasper
and jay they're gonna give it to you the
whole time i noticed that saka did not
make this spot well he was he was added
last year oh okay but but yeah
he's he's
i mean we're definitely warming up to
him and uh he's he he's found his niche
in the house in the house in the home
ecosystem
but yeah he's not going to make my list
here but yeah just to see that certain
kind of love that christy needed that
was different than the kind of love that
i can give that you can only get from a
dog that adores you like a god
i guess
so it's just been super sweet to see
their connection and for that to be
just a part just a part of
really seeing how
a connection with an animal can really
be very transformative it can be it can
be transformative therapy and uh it has
been for her and
so for him to be a bona fide member of
our family
is is super special uh okay my number
one
is my trip with my wife to big sur
uh which was also to celebrate our 20th
anniversary which
uh it actually was our 20th anniversary
we we you know we had originally planned
to go i told i talked about again
there's another episode where we talked
all about this trip so i won't go into
too many details but we had planned on
this being our 20th anniversary in italy
of course
that kind of travel didn't happen this
year so we went to big sur and i in in a
similar way as you were talking about
with christy
the level of intensity of our connection
during that time
was something that we have you know that
was the pinnacle of the intensity of our
sort of singular connection to each
other this year it was an incredible
it's hard to get that level of
connectivity right when you're at home
with kids
with the jobs that you both have and
you're in and and both very busy and so
yeah we have the we have the fleeting
moments that we through throughout the
year but there was this
focus on one another and we took a whole
week you know we basically were up there
for a whole week
and uh because we were like we're taking
a whole week because we we're gonna be
in italy but we can't be so let's just
make it a week
and
uh you know we we still talk about that
we and we we made us end up going to big
sur for our anniversary from here on out
probably not because we'd like to go to
new places but we talked about it
because
it's a super special place and then
the the the type of connection that we
experienced and the type of sort of the
the level of the communication that we
were able to have and the clarity of
communication that we were able to have
for that week was
just
you know one of the highlights of our
marriage honestly and then i talked a
little bit about you know sort of the
spiritual processing that took place on
that trip
you know once you leave an organized
religion uh you're no longer really part
of a recognizable faith community
uh and there's not ritual and gathering
in a book
you know that's one of the one of the
one of the wonderful things about
organized religion in my mind
is the structure in the community and
the ritual and the practice
and that's one of the reasons that's so
successful and that's one of the reasons
that the community communities are so
vibrant because people need that kind of
connection
just most a lot of people need that kind
of connection
now
since i no longer believe in a
particular religion
and i'm not no longer a part of a
religious community
the spiritual processing can be
something that happens sort of just like
in in in spurts
and happens sort of
on an individual basis and it doesn't
happen as much in community and it
doesn't happen as much
there's not as much structure and
direction to it and it can be super
beautiful
that week for us and a couple of
different moments
and just the sort of
the spiritual connection and i'm not
going to go into too many details but
the spiritual connection that we had was
also kind of feeding into
the just human connection that we were
having and the love connection that we
were having and the way that all those
things kind of played together
i talked about some of those
realizations that jessie was coming to
and she told and she talked about that
on her twitter as well
but that was one of the things that made
that special is that hey we don't you
know we go
months
sometimes without having a meaningful
spiritual connection
in the context of our of family we have
really sweet moments we have really
loving moments we have intense
moments of connection with one another
but sometimes we don't have
what i would consider spiritual progress
and to be able to get that uh that week
was something that
i i greatly value that's a good number
one my friend yeah my number one uh
maybe a process elimination you could
figure it out was
sending
lily off to college i devoted
an overly emotional
commemorative episode to unpacking the
details and all of the tears
associated with that but
you know just realizing that
um
i
our family is different now it was a
rite of passage for her
and a successful one
she's experiencing success
in her first semester away her first
quarter away she's back home she's
finished it up she's she's got that
under her belt she's doing great it's
not without its challenges it's not
without its moments of being
uh
afraid or
lonely or you know
all the things that you might think
of an experience she's had tastes of all
of that but it's been uh very much
uh a positive in trajectory for her
which is a huge relief for christie and
i
and but then also realizing that
like our status as people have changed
like i have a child who's well i have an
adult
child yeah who's out of the house
and when she comes back it is different
and i was being very dramatic about the
way that i was processing it and i
enjoyed that because it made it very
meaningful
and but yeah it's like she comes back
and it's like how do you feel being back
home for christmas break she said it
feels like kind of feels the same but i
know it really doesn't and
in every way and for us it's like things
will never be the same we've we've
crossed the threshold into
um
a new era
as
as parents and as a family
and uh
i'm grateful that it's going so well for
her and for us
you know that like she surprised me and
when i came home from work two nights
ago and she was there she had moved her
flight and she came back early
and it was like
yeah i almost burst into tears of
happiness to see her
but at the same but i didn't actually i
didn't go that far it was like okay this
is kind of our new normal and then we're
moving into the future and it's like
every everything associated with this
can't be the most dramatic thing because
it will be absolutely depleting
um
but
yeah it's i just feel like
it was a successful
rite of passage
and
for her it
i i think it will only happen once i got
i got two more that will have their own
versions of rite of passage but this was
the year of that and absolutely became
my number one and when she put her hand
in that glove that had all the ants on
the inside of it and stung her
right when she got to college that was
one heck of a rite of passage as well
they did that at our college right
that's why they do that at all he told
you but not me
but you know what i'm saying right so
that's my number one
and there you have it we have no zeros
that's it
you got and uh
you got a wreck that's in line with this
my recommendation for you
is
do the same thing i think we made this
recommendation last year but it is
it's
i would have liked to have taken more
time
um but just even if it's taking 30
minutes and going back through your
camera roll i wrote down
every month of the year
and then
everything that
was the beginning of something or a
you know i wrote down like probably 35
things and i did not think that would
happen but when you go through like you
said go through your calendar you go
through your photo roll
um
you can go through your email or your
journal like all these things will jog
your memory and just writing that down
like i have this record
of
my of every year that we've done this
that i can kind of go back to
uh by month and more than just the 10
things the smaller things
as well it just mean a lot espec when i
went back and i read last year's and
prep for this year
a lot of memories flooded back so i just
i recommend you take the time to do that
for yourself and then if you have a
podcast turn it into an episode yeah it
makes a great episode uh speaking of
podcasts this one will be back
on january 10th 2022.
in the meantime
you probably haven't listened to every
single episode and you know what it is
okay if you want to listen to another
podcast but we prefer you just listen to
make sure you archived versions of ours
just make sure it does not replace this
one in your heart hashtag gearbusiness
let us know uh
what reactions you have to this
and
we wish you the best through the end of
the year
happy holidays happy new year we will
see you in 2022.
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]